lebanon's leadership is facing growing
anger over the deadly blasts that have
killed more than 150 people
and injured thousands more shock is
turning to fury
authorities responded with force when
protesters gathered outside parliament
opponents accused the government of
corruption incompetence
and failing to avert an economic
meltdown
french president emmanuel macron flew
into beirut promising aid from the
international community
but he also says there will be no blank
checks and he insists there must be
internal reform
from the top
as the people of beirut come together to
clean up the debris from tuesday's
catastrophic
explosion world leaders are lining up to
provide aid
french president macron landed in beirut
addressing the anger felt by the people
towards the corruption regarded as
making the blast possible
and that has plagued the country for
decades
he has also promised assistance
what i can guarantee you is that this
aid will be transparent
it will go to the field and it will not
go in the hands of the corrupt
lebanon is a former french protectorate
and the two countries still have close
ties today
surrounded by crowds macron listened to
the outrage and pleas for help
while chance of revolution and end the
regime sounded all around
i am here today i am going to propose a
new political pact this afternoon
and i will come back by september 1st
and if it has not been obtained i will
take responsibility for it
macron later announced the launch of an
international conference in the coming
days
with the aim of raising funds to support
the people of beirut
[Applause]
we are no longer able to continue this
way
in this situation people do not have
enough money to continue what they
started
the country cannot take it anymore
we have been fighting for 50 years in
order to raise our family in these
circumstances that we live in
now we're finished we have been working
for our retirement
but they've finished us
hopes rest on an international aid
effort to pull together
so the residents of beirut can rebuild
their homes
their city and their community
let's bring in our correspondent in the
lebanese capital
salman is with us now hi razan if people
have been protesting near the parliament
in beirut what more can you tell us
about that
uh indeed to me uh people uh there was
there were uh a clashes between the
security forces and the protesters
and an anti-uh government uh
demonstration that took place yesterday
near the lebanese parliament
uh and uh the security forces they uh
deployed tear gas
on dozens of protesters who gathered
around
uh the parliament uh to ask the
government to resign
uh since they believe the government is
responsible for the explosion that took
place on tuesday
because the 2750 tons of
ammonium nitrate were stored in a
warehouse in beirut's port
with no proper security measures
we saw those images of the french
president emmanuel macron walking
through the streets of beirut he has
promised
international assistance to lebanon but
he's also calling on the country's
leaders
to launch anti-corruption reforms how is
that message
received
yes this morning the lebanese
authorities
they took into custody 16 individuals
and as part of an investigation into the
beirut poet's
explosion and on the other hand they
assigned an investigative
committee and they gave the committee
four days
in order to claim who is responsible for
this explosion
and the central bank froze ordered to
freeze
the accounts of heads of lebanese
customs
and beirut ports officials
and on the other hand forty four
thousand
uh lebanese the people signed an online
petition
uh asking to place lebanon under the
french mandate for the next ten years
since they completely lost the trust in
their own government and its ability to
manage the country
well it's important to mention that a
lot of people are still missing i mean
how is the rescue effort going
uh well the rescue efforts are still in
progress
and just uh this morning two dead bodies
were found under the robin
and the officials they expect the death
toll to rise within the next
few hours uh since the rescue efforts
are still in progress
and the minister of health just
announced this is the official number
just announced that 154 people were dead
uh after the explosion uh uh more than
5000 people were injured
and along with 300 000 people who have
completely lost their hopes
dw's residence hallman reporting from
beirut thank you